bachelor allama Chris soules arrested
after authorities say he fled the scene
of a deadly car crash in his home state
of Iowa
chris is currently in custody after
allegedly slamming into a
tractor-trailer and killing the driver
the incident happened Monday night Chris
was apparently driving a pickup truck
and rear-ended the trailer which ended
up in a ditch the trailers driver was
taken by ambulance to a hospital where
he died Chris was booked on the charge
of leaving the scene of an accident that
resulted in a death the 35 year old was
just with et last month where he opened
up about life after the bachelor I still
live in the middle of nowhere you know
so it's it's when I meet somebody it's
like hey you're really cool but I'll see
if I'm gonna fly ten hours away from you
and then oh you know we can text for a
while man yeah well hopefully I'll see
you a month through six or so yeah still
challenging you know the reason I went
on the show is not was still real you
know the reason that the dating in the
middle of nowhere
for me still exists
[Music]